verdammte du bist raus
hallo meine lieben will zurück zur treue
web mitkomme hdi hallöchen und
willkommen zurück wie er sich wieder auf
den knopf gefunden wir gehen hier schon
wie man creeper nicht halten sollte und
zwar sind hier 20 creeper unter mir also
ich glaube es immer mehr als 20 pieper
die sich herum backen und der bombe
hatte zwar das letzte mal eigentlich
schon geschafft allerdings hat er
vergessen auf den knopf am anfang zu
drücken und hat dementsprechend keine
übelkeit und keine sprungkraft bekommen
deswegen mache das ganze natürlich
nochmal denn wir sind ja real boss und
so kennt man ja von uns beiden wir
würden nie irgendwas überspringen wo ich
hab's auch gleich geschafft ich habe es
gleich geschafft oh ja ja auch schon
hier wieder auf dem level ich wieder auf
dein blog aber ich will auf seinem level
okay wie kommt man da jetzt hoch trotz
sogar ohne sprungkraft geschäft
aufzubauen
genau einfach mal genau den gleichen weg
hab ich eigentlich genutzt sondern bin
ich in den wald rein und was euch dann
gemacht ich habe keine ahnung also in
diesem herz allgemein ist glaube ich
nichts drin
wir müssen halt einfach guck mal hier
sind solche holzstämme wir müssen da
einfach weiter den weg entlang
ich bin auf dem herz drauf und ich bin
mit dem herz etwas drin der druckplatte
rechtfertigte teleportiert da wieder
schilder müssen
das war ein gewisser hochgesprungen
erreicht den spareffekt immer noch habe
eben sagt dana dotierten also
normalerweise sollte er weg seine milch
der sollte bald mehr willst
wahrscheinlich ähnlich über die
druckplatte gelaufen
mayotte stimmten nicht sogar gelaufen
stellen kann es mir möglich geben ich
habe keine op
wer gibt mir keine op genau ich spiele
hier hast du dein opa ich dachte jetzt
geburtstag heute gewährt hast du denkst
du ich habe nirgendwo ist obwohl wir
hier leichter geld und wissen dass da
nie gesehen oder sonst wie schnell sich
das mal so ich wollte ich gleich schnell
wieder ganz am anfang ich auch ihr zu
dem schreiben
ich wollte die luft schießt genau in dem
moment bist du mir reingesprungen
operiert den tag hinterher und jetzt geh
jetzt leute und diesmal würdest du mich
nicht komme ich wollte ich wollte ich
eigentlich nur erschreckend nur über den
ozean fließen alter ich habe immer so
angst ist für mich ab schießt man unten
steht was drauf da steht club down the
waterfront ecclestone ist sexy
da müssen wir rein springen wurden
nördlich springer durch darauf woran
genau in das wasser um den gleisen herum
das geht doch voll stimmt gerechte
platte ich wollte ich gebeutelte ich
wurde geboren ich auch okay okay du bist
du da bist du ich sehr hart mit dem
schwert in der hand
einzel wettbewerb ich würde sagen ja wir
können jetzt wahrscheinlich schützt
nämlich rund
ich helfe die kräfte hier brauchst gar
nicht was für bis amman
diese komme weiß natürlich dass sich der
unglaublichste pvp könig bin deswegen
machen die auch extra wegen mir dem
neuen modus aufgabe hd sagen ich weiß
natürlich schon wieder neue ich sag dazu
auch nichts ich weiß natürlich schon
wieder neue modus heißt weil com hat
werder schon verraten bestimmt
buchstaben also endspiel wurde es heißt
konkret dass cain motiv ist ein schmaler
grat game roddick vor ort controllers
mode die gehrys mod aber nur mit
grundkräfte ein diamant wenn auch klein
aber gegen diamanten gewaltig sagen die
auch ein kleiner diamant ist ein diamant
diamanten hühnchen da unten gesehen habe
ich voll knuffig voll die
massentierhaltung bewusst was du dass du
den namen angeht reagiert werde ich von
überall abgeschlossen jedoch nicht wir
haben nicht mal einen quickpoll aber du
ich hab so viele eier mit denen ich dich
nachher immer runter kicken können wir
müssen darunter das war sogar richtig
duo ist das look back wild chefs travel
leisure and placed on the grid wochen
ein level ein schalter nur wo finden wir
den wahrscheinlichen kann dann hätte er
bestimmt unten bei die rola geben wo
zwischen hühnern mainz ist gestern schon
also wofür um die sonst so viele hühner
hier stehen sagt mir dass ein loch wie
bei captain minecraft wo tausend user
drin stehen ich mag ich bin schon
zehnmal rumgelaufen jetzt gerade
also ich sehe keine fest welche sie
keine hühner gackern hühner hast du hier
oben sehe ich keine
obwohl doch vorher eventuell alter oder
hat die chest eventuell das design von
einem großteil kürzel diese geräusche
die hühner
ich höre die ganze zeit welche stimmen
du aber ich bin aber jetzt nicht mehr
hause jetzt höre ich die genau richtige
zeichen ist das vielleicht ein zeichen
dass hier genau dagegen da ist nichts
schlechtes sagen will dass du die nicht
gesehen hast die ist doch da oben hier
diese unter diesem holzbrett wie solche
gesehen da von dem ein blog hat zu
dieser bisschen meine anderen seite kann
man diese ist ein hoch willkommener
letzter hoch ricoh will hier raus ich
werde hier alle an meinte er könnte man
auch blöcke zeit stören von daher die
waren ja schon zerstört ihr habt es
kaputt kümmern
so und jetzt wo ist der eingang der weil
ich bin jetzt übrig
ich bin darüber gesprochen einen fall
als sie mich gesehen papier nicht wert
erstes oben es hat gewonnen hat nicht
gewonnen
der erste oben ist hat gewonnen nicht
töten durst geschossen was uns stört
ja das war ein richtig starker schutz
bedrohter gefallen wie er ist das
gemacht ich finde das war richtig stark
dieser schuss muss ein gutachter ihre
kirche zu holen ich aber kann ich dafür
dass ich so eine gute range ob du hast
mich runter geschossen du sack als
welche wir ganz am anfang bei diesem
herz und hier sind immer so packte leute
bei mir ja ich hab das aber eben und
eventuell wären wir dann wieder gebohrt
eventuell stelle ich auch gerade weil
ich noch einmal das herz habt wir man
muss immer gemeint anderen auto nicht
oder ich wünsche mir die schüsse
ich hab den dingen der musste darauf
machen
altach könnte man die songs von mai an
wie jung das ist total doof mit den
einstellungen weil man nachher so alles
ist so extrem laut ich habe eine
lautstärke bei drei prozent der lap
laser sonne gold blog ok alkoholika ist
hier durchlaufen
ja die türen sind weggefallen das ist
doch schon mal sprung sprung spaß ich
bin runter gefallen was meint ihr
millionen gefallen wir das bestimmt
irgendwo was wieder hochzukommen als sie
nicht oder soll ich jetzt einmal rum
drum rum laufen dieses gebäude will ich
doch nicht dafür
ich glaube ich muss wirklich einmal
hinten rum laufen alter mache ich schon
mal die sprünge nicht wird das nicht
schaffen beim ersten durchlauf kannst du
schon mal gucken ob irgendwo essen ist
aber ich bin auch wieder gefallen
verdammt ersten rumlaufen
es habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen und
die tiere davon nicht fürchten oder ob
wohlstand nicht in der regel dass man
die tiere also theoretisch dürfen wir
hier die hühner und so weiter können
lass es einfach gleich machen oder
schweine oder so stimmen wie so wenig
darauf nicht gekommen
ich habe auch so viele sportler als ich
einmal zu den münchen rhein gefallen
wenn er als ich einmal zu den münchen
rhein gefallen im frühjahr wieder
tragisches kindheit früher aldi erzählen
sie von ihren problemen herr kräftig bin
einmal in einen ich kann da nicht lang
laufen
ihr freund ihr habt gerade gesehenen der
aufnahme ich da oben versucht mal
darüber zu sprinten
bei mir der kuckuck mehr allzu sehr
ruhig aber da ist ja jetzt gesehen aber
ich bin euer herz darüber gesprungen um
nie die kacke war das denn porsche
wieder nicht geschafft die sprünge sind
so gemein er freunde gehabt aber
wahrscheinlich gesehenen der aufnahme
dass es so richtig richtig blöd war
gerade in der fecht mittelalter allein
schon jiji
älter ist im saal stimmt er stimmt das
schwierige sprünge
ich komm ich brauch essen alter ich
brauche essen
also ich hätte gerne welches abgeben
hier darunter liegt ein stück fleisch
ein gedanke weiter das ist doch auf
welcher schwierigkeit wir das ganze
komme ich ja so schwer
ja diese ganzen mops überall es ist halt
macht ne halbe wo bist du endlich
abgespannt ich kann nicht mal mehr
sprinten ich noch essen
oh mein gott du verdammter peter du hast
jetzt bio-eier
ich freue mich wundert so viele mox sind
die habe ich will gerade geholt nicht im
griff für conny die geblieben bob die
mod die dings die mobs eben gerade die
kamera nicht von mir die kam wirklich
vom spiel hätte ich ja ich würde ich
gerade die genau vor die erscheint sind
die kam von mir ich hab mir gekauft aber
ansonsten die ganzen körper die gebannt
wirklich alle von der karte ich finde es
auch total krass wie spielen auf sie
haben einfach warm ist ihr stein und
haben einfach mal so viele monster auf
der karte worte mit zu dir wenn ich okay
haben wir mit mops sterbe die du getan
hast dann der ja immer wieder kritik am
ob ich dachte mir immer so toll auf der
karte hier nämlich den namen immer viel
zu sehr am herzen
das ist die der künstler heim komme es
auch vor hofft hätte kosten ich hatte
jonas man nicht so viel treue wurde wird
die troika mitteln blöden neuen
profilbild damit diesem troll theron
wird das ist ein toller orden habe ich
verleihe er habe ich auch dir bekommen
habe ich aber durch die ganzen tross an
die elbe kommen nicht an die vom feuer
und vergibt hab da haben die gesagt die
die tolle organisation ja der kontrollen
das ist auch so krank ich bekomm zuvor
diese karte hat überall animationen
ich springe bei diese sprünge ich
springe man diese sprünge und überall
machst ja kopf hast du gesehen der war
ein blogger weg ja das hatte ich nämlich
auch jetzt geht's und jetzt müssen wir
uns anstrengen müssen wir das packen und
west an genau dem scheitern
wo ich auch eben gescheitert bin es ist
nicht genau der jetzt ist so gemein
unfair desto gemeinde du schaffst das
kommt wollen wir sagen wenn einer den
schafft dann darf der andere sich in
worden
grüße des wortes dieser episode trollen
total verdammte du bist kumpel
und nie hatte die renten ja ich bin am
arsch die nächste folge kommt morgen bei
bäume und dann sehen wir uns wieder
chips und alter